[Music]
hi everyone good afternoon I'm really
excited to be here
before I introduce myself I thought that
I would get a sense of who are audiences
so one of the first things and I have to
keep on being close to the Mac because
I'm using mines so it may go on to sleep
so we'll try not to make that happen so
I want to understand who is here today
first so let me just ask a couple of
questions so how many of you are
actually developers here okay how many
of you are in a security data privacy
data protection legal compliance
function okay all right so majority of
the people so I'm talking to the right
group here how many of you are working
for companies that have presence in more
than one country okay great so also more
than half and how many of you are
already on GCP and how many of you are
on GCP as well as have data on the other
public cloud providers like as your AWS
and how many of you have still some of
your data on-premise okay so it seems
like more than 50% of people here are in
the security data protection function
are on cloud on GCP have hybrid type of
a work environment okay great so that's
really good to know that helps me tailor
the presentation here a little bit so a
little bit about me I'm Rashi Mittal I
am working on data custodian responsible
for go to market commercialization
customer engagement and talking to
customer understanding how we should
continue developing the solution so
we've partnered this product has come
out of our partnership with Google so it
is a layer of data visibility and data
control for customers
or sitting on GCP so that's what the
product is about so you know before I go
a little bit further and talk about data
and data protection and the solution
itself I thought that I would discuss a
little bit about why s AP is focused on
doing this so as ap general tso majority
the people are aware of you know no SI p
yes okay
sometimes in Silicon Valley you'd be
surprised I get questions around Oh what
is s AP so so that's good to know so I
say P has been responsible and has been
its purpose and its mission has always
been to drive to make sure that
enterprises are running better and oh
that happened gave me a second so s AP
has been I'm gonna stay here don't want
this to go to sleep again so s AP has
been a response it's you know its
mission has been to make sure that
enterprises run better and we have been
for years been part of making sure that
we have extremely innovative solutions
around business processes and so we see
data custodian as an extension of that
as we provide an extra layer of
visibility and control of your
end-to-end data on a Google cloud
platform so I'm you know as I'm going
through introduction I'm going to go
through sort of the data custodian
features why the solution has been
developed the demo and the question and
answers um so first let's talk about
data so we know that we're living in a
world where there is a lot of data
doesn't matter which organization you're
part of you're probably monetizing on
your data it's often the lifeline for
most customers if you are in financial
services the financial data is extremely
important if you are in retail I'm
assuming a lot of customers here are
from the retail industry so they are
using data to for their operations for
making sure that they are selling and
putting the right products out there if
you are in healthcare
very regulated industry but you know the
data volume keeps on increasing with
genomics with clinical studies a lot of
your records which used to be on paper
now our electronic health records the
volume of data just keeps on increasing
right and that's that's a fact so the
question becomes what should I do about
this data and how do I protect it so
you're here at Google next and your
majority of the people here are already
on cloud so I don't necessarily need to
speak too much about the benefits of
public cloud but I will say that you
know the reason why a lot of you have
placed your data on public cloud is
because of the various benefits which
include scalability elasticity pricing
reduced implementation time even so if
you look at the studies only a small
percentage of companies have a public
only cloud architecture and what I mean
by that is you may have some of your
data on public cloud but many companies
are hesitant to put all of their data
especially sensitive data or data maybe
in some of their data maybe European
data etc on public cloud for various
reasons so can anybody say why that may
be true that the cloud adoption is still
not where we would want to see where I'm
sure Google would want to see loss of
control any other any other answers okay
perception okay great yeah so I think
those are all very good answers so we
did an ASIC survey recently and in that
ASIC survey you know not just because
this is a security session but security
did come as sort of number third after
implementation issues and migration cost
issues as the reason why cloud adoption
is not where it should be or if you know
where Google would want for example
cloud adoption to be
and but the security so we went a little
deeper into that okay what does security
mean right and security could mean some
of the identity access management issues
but it is a lot of things around
perception it is an emotional thing for
a lot of customers who are used to
having the data on premise for a very
long time and now putting it on public
cloud they have lost the control they've
given control to a third party now and
there is a lack of visibility there is a
lack of complete transparency as to
where the data is and that is a
continued concern which is a concern
we're trying to we're hoping to solve
with ICP data custodian one of the other
concerns that I've heard so you know ICP
is a European company we so I've
traveled to Europe and I've talked to
some of our customers there some of our
salespeople there and I think one of the
concerns that comes up and this concern
is very relevant with the Facebook
Cambridge analytical case that recently
happened well if we give access to our
data is it being accessed in an
unauthorized unintended way that's a
huge concern for many customers as well
and that access so you know it's
surprising when you look at a lot of
reaches people think oh it must you know
all these breaches must be happening
because of hackers in fact interestingly
it's your own employees often because of
either negligence or because they've
gone rogue for example and that leads to
a lot of you know issues around some
type of a breach et cetera so your own
cloud provider access as well as access
by your own employees is something that
is a huge concern and especially when
you put the data on public cloud
platform the concern becomes a while
will I have visibility and control and
can I have some level of full control
over that so the third I think points
that you know talked about transparency
and control talked about cloud provider
access I think the third issue that also
becomes a concern for some customers or
a challenge if you will for many
customers are the data protection
regulations that are varying so how many
of you
hard and our have worked with gdpr okay
so majority the room right so it's just
went to in fact there's GDP are there
are also various almost sixty countries
I was just reading something last night
there are almost 60 countries that have
varying data protection regulations and
after GDP are going into effect I'm sure
there will be other countries that are
not only coming up with new regulations
so cloud is you know globally connected
when you place your data in a globally
connected cloud I think for some
customers the concern becomes which law
will apply right so the concern is not
just can I you know the concern could be
data localization and data residency
laws that exist all throughout the world
but the other concern is which law
applies if my data does move around and
that's where there are some needs and
for having something around geolocation
so given the various challenges around
privacy around transparency around
control I think the question becomes
well how can companies benefit from
public cloud and still retain control of
their business data so this is where you
know we thought that trust but verify is
an extremely important concept so you
know we're we're moving towards you know
innovation right we're here in the Bay
Area everybody wants to innovate quickly
there's a lot of data the data volume is
growing so the choice or the option is
not to you know keep all your data
stored on premise right cloud is has a
lot of benefits as we talked about it
and you want to be able to use public
cloud but how do you stay in public
cloud but still be able to have some
level of control and visibility of your
data well you can have a third party
that can help you with verification
around that and our a Sox survey
actually helped in that response as well
that a verification mechanism with a
third party that is already has a
relationship with the enterprise's makes
a lot of sense so which is where s ap
data custodian comes in s AP data
custodian
a little dashboard over there it is a
SAS application that we have developed
and the first phase of dissolution is
generally available so I'll go a little
bit deeper into what this solution is so
before I go into that we have defined
data custodians to be responsible for
the implementation of business rules
that relate to the access and protection
of business data so as I mentioned there
are two key phases of our solution there
is data transparency which is generally
available which helps with monitoring
and reporting of data access storage and
movement and processing of your data in
the public cloud so you will have more
visibility into how your data is
accessed how it's stored where it's
being moved and where it's being
processed in the public cloud and the
data control is our second part of the
solution which is going to be available
throughout the rest of the year and
we're working on that so we have a very
robust policy engine that we have
developed out of data custodian so an
example for that would be that you know
you are a company and you have some
sensitive data is sitting in Germany
maybe your HR data in Germany and you
may want to keep some of that data only
within Germany on public cloud you can
develop a policy through our portal and
we are able to in the data control piece
actually enforce those policies so in
the first section we're giving you a lot
of robust visibility monitoring
reporting and the second section we're
able to help you with the enforcement of
those policies and I will go through a
demo so this will all become more clear
so as I mentioned the transparency is
going to help you answer the following
key questions where is my data stored
how has the data been moved and
processed and who is accessing my data
and from which location so I think some
people here mentioned that they are
concerned about what is happening to the
data once it is in public cloud that's
what this part of the product helps with
and I think I also heard control over
there so this is where the second part
of our the functionalities which are
going to come soon are going to help
so it's a it's helping with your
governance it's helping with your
compliance and essentially this is where
STP truly becomes quote unquote data
custodian where we're able to help
enforce the geolocation controls for
data access storage processing and
movement so I think the question I have
received often is well why as ap right
and I started out with saying a.s.a.p
helps with enterprises you know run
better
we have been masters and have a lot of
expertise around business processes but
further along we have a lot of expertise
in governance risk and compliance we
have a lot of knowledge about public
cloud platforms and even so we are
actually independent of public cloud
platforms and I think that's where that
concept concept of trust but verify
becomes really important so this is why
it makes sense for s AP to take come in
and you know you may already have an
existing relationship with sa P you may
be using our various applications our
various business processes and this will
be yet something else that we can help
you with while you're in public cloud so
this is where I'm gonna do a little demo
for you okay great
so this is okay so this is our dashboard
so let's say that you have butters
there you go so let's say that you have
you know you're already starting to use
data custodian you come in Monday
morning maybe your cloud analyst you
know wants to make sure that they have
full visibility of your data on public
cloud so they will sign into this
homepage they'll sign into the cockpit
view and they're gonna see a few things
before they see that though I wanted to
go into the mouth my cloud page my clout
tab which is a very important tab so
let's say before you have so I've talked
about that we have a very robust policy
engine with data custodian so before you
develop the policies you can come to
this page and are able to see where all
your data is distributed globally on
Google cloud platform so this is sort of
your data placement for you and you can
see that your data is spread all over
the world some of it is in India some is
Europe some in the US so just having a
visibility of how your data spread out
is you know exactly helping with that
visibility that we were talking about
similarly you can see how where the data
is being accessed from so some of your
data may be sitting in Europe but it's
being accessed whether to buy your
employee maybe a Google support engineer
from you know United States you can also
see sorry it's a little slow
well technically it should be showing
data movement so let's just pretend that
it did and we'll go back to the home
page and and we'll show you data
movement in another view here so so the
again going back to the home page so we
have this concept of unions that'd be a
point with data custodian the concept of
union is a geolocation defined area
where your data can be placed stored
moved or processed so here you can see
that we have you know us-china Union
which probably is slightly less
realistic but you can have a Canada
Brazil Union so you may want your data
to be staying in access and process and
move between just Canada and Brazil and
you can have a European Union and I will
go into the you know policy management
so you'll be able to see how we are
developing the policies as well so you
know you can have the European Union and
I'll just click on that and there you
can see that you have on the corner here
on the left-hand side you can see how
the compliance has been for the European
Union in the last few days you can see
what alerts have come up so you have
five level of alerts so a level one
alert is not as scary probably as a
level five alert so level five alert may
be an example you know you have very
strict German regulations you want some
of your HR data to stay within Germany
but for some reason it has moved outside
of Germany and that might be a risk
level that you have assigned five and
that would show up as an alert so we're
seeing of risk level of four we're
seeing how the risk overview has been
for the Union the European Union in the
last seven days and on the side here you
can you have a lot of other interesting
information about the European Union and
how much data is stored there and how
much if it is so there's also a tagging
functionality as part of our solution so
you can tag the data to be highly
sensitive or less sensitive and so here
we distribute most of the data here it
seems is you know sensitive and you can
see total storage size
well as resources so we have data
custodian at the infrastructure level so
what we are actually showing the
visibility of is you know all your
infrastructure level data lots of
virtual machines your disks your buckets
so you can see you know how what the
resources look like for this particular
union so I'm gonna go to an actual to
the Union itself and see if you have any
alerts there actually before I do that
let me show you how to make a policy so
because you know the policy engine is a
very important part of the solution so
I'm going to go and see European Union
so I will show you the so here to define
a policy and this is something that you
can do and is you know you're gonna have
a name of the policy you can have an
action of allow or deny you will have an
operation so the for operations right
now that we are looking into our access
placement movement and processing you
will have resource classes so this is a
very interesting part of our policy
engines so either you can say all my
resources on Google cloud platform or
you can get more granular so you can
either choose it by resource classes so
you can say all my virtual machines or
all my buckets or you can also choose be
even more granular and say choose a
specific bucket so that the bucket in
Germany with that German data HR data
might be something that you can pick and
have a specific policy for that so you
you choose how granular you want to be
now you also have to choose the location
so your union is your data is sitting in
European Union that's your resource
location and now you this is an actually
an access policy right so you are saying
I actually don't want some of my data to
be accessed from the United States so I
don't want my data all of my data
sitting in European Union to be accessed
from United States so that's something
that you can choose and you know you can
choose other countries as well
and you can choose so if it's access
there are two accesses that we are
monitoring so it's your own customer
access your own employee access as well
as Google access so you can choose
either all that you don't want any of
your access from a Google Support
Engineer or your own employee access to
happen from United States because you
are concerned about you know your u.s.
regulation you're concerned that under
Patriot Act maybe the government is
going to somehow you know want some of
that data which is sitting you know and
so that's why you want to really keep
some of your data defined and controlled
and not being accessed outside of Europe
and that's that could be a good reason
of why you want to do that or you could
have some other technology or other
reasons and then you have to define a
risk level which can be lowest low
medium higher highest and then that's a
summary of a policy that you would have
so going back to the home page I'm not
sure if there are any questions I'm
going to go back to the European Union
and show you what happens when an alert
comes up let me have to change it to the
last three months
hmm oh maybe that's what it is
so I mean this this is you know we've
generated some data for this particular
demo so it's showing a lot of alerts and
a lot of these red alerts so I'm gonna
click on one of these red alerts to see
what's going on so as I click on add we
see that there has been an access
violation so I just went through the
policy that we just developed which was
the policy that we don't want your
European Union data to be accessed by
somebody sitting in the United States
except in this case there was an actual
violation that happened and so in this
particular case during our forum our
transparency where our product is today
you can do a couple of different things
you can get more information about that
and see why that may have happened so in
this case it may be that one of your
employees from the European Union is
actually traveling to United States and
you feel comfortable that you know
comfortable with them accessing this
data if that's the case then you can
verify it by saying you know okay or you
know employee moving and then submit
that and then that will make the policy
go away so let's just do that
and then you know as soon as that pilot
you have resolved the policy and it goes
from red to green another option would
be that you can actually change the
policy itself so maybe there have been
some changes in way or did you want your
data to be accessed from maybe you're
now comfortable with it all being
accessed from us because you've opened
up a new you know Center in the US and
you know a lot of your US employees are
going to be accessing it so you could
also go ahead and completely change the
policy and no longer have this policy so
those are the various things you can do
with the alerts and I just wanted to
show you one other thing quickly before
I open it up for Q&A so you also have
the option to actually run reports which
is something that your data privacy
officer or your legal compliance
department may want to use so
and depending on the dates you will have
a lot more information around what the
alert trends have been the risk level of
these alerts resolvers is unresolved
alerts the data type etc and you know
again in this case because we've
generated some data for this demo you
can see there are a lot of unresolved
alerts hopefully that's not going to
happen hopefully you're not actually
having a lot of these violations you're
having a fewer violations and you're
able to investigate and resolve them on
a day to day basis so that was a quick
demo we also have a lot of our team here
technical you know so and our developers
and our product owners are so happy to
answer any questions so I can answer
them and we also have other people who
can help answer and we also have people
from Google here
[Music]